فضل 25 من اكتوبر تشرين الاول عام 2021
تارجحت مواقف رئيس مجلس السياده السوداني
والقائد العام للقوات المسلحه الفريق عبد
الفتاح البرهان بين الدعوه لحوار الوطني
شامل ودعم كل مبادره الحل السلميه من جهه
وبين ما يقوله انصار الحكم المدني من جهه
ثانيه من ان المؤسسه العسكريه هي التي
انقلبت على المسار الديمقراطيه الانتقالي
واعاده البلاد الى الحكم العسكري بحسبها
هؤلاء في 13 من فبراير شباط الماضي صرح
رئيس مجلس السياده الانتقالي في السودان
عبد الفتاح البرهان لان مبعوث الامين
العام للامم المتحده
وسيط يدعو الجميع للحوار ولا يحق له تقديم
مبادره في الرابع عشر من فبراير طرح
البرهان مبادره من اربعه محاور لحل الازمه
في السودان خلال لقاء مع وصفي مفوضيه
الاتحاد الافريقي في الثالث من مارس اثار
تراجع البرهان معلنا دعمه للمبادره الاميه
التي تقودها
الامم المتحده لدعم الانتقال بالسودان
وترحيبه بجميع المبادرات الداخليه
والخارجيه في خطوه مفاجاه في الخامس مليون
و تموز الماضي اعلن البرهان عدم مشاركه
المؤسسه العسكريه في الحوار الوطني الذي
تدوره الذي تدوره الاليه الثلاثيه الاميه
وفي الرابع عشر اغسطس اب اكد البرهان ان
القوات المسلحه السودانيه لن تنحاز لاي
طرف في الفتره الانتقاليه وفي الثانيه
والعشرين من سبتمبر من العام الجاري عاد
البرهان التاكيد فالثاني والعشرين من
سبتمبر ايلول ان المؤسسه العسكريه تنظر
بايجابيه للمبادرات العديده التي تعمل على
تحقيق الوفاق الوطني في السودان